foreign
good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy monday we hope everyone had a
great exciting weekend if i saw you this
weekend at two of my shows maybe two of
the most hmm
how do i explain it maybe two of the
most inspiring shows i've had for real
that's what i heard yeah like everyone
was a buzz no i mean obviously like my
performance was inspiring like you know
literally brought people to tears
but i i did a show um in aurelia ontario
this weekend at a casino and it was
it was pretty shocking honestly like i
would say usually it's 100 toasters like
and i can lean into my toasty vibes like
that's my cross to bear and any time i
say something even remotely toasty like
i know people scream and it's like
such a great safe environment to be in
but this was a show
um near toronto where i had already done
toronto so the people who drove two
hours from toronto it was like true
toasters
it was 50 those people and then 50 like
people just in the casino like people
who live on the reservation
um and it was actually like incredibly
scary to uh perform in front of like
people who had no idea who i was so like
it was a different show
i was a little bit more like explaining
who i was but i felt like so good and so
comfortable on stage and i saw
all these women the next day at
breakfast and they were like not my
target demo they were like
you know they had like a girls weekend
at the casino they were like 50 60 and
they just came up to me they were like
your show was amazing and i was like oh
my god what
thank you and it was just like really
great show then i ended in terrytown
like right by my home
new york jews it was just so great that
is so great yeah
um well i'm happy for you know that i am
i'm glad to hear the show is
is better than ever and obviously i had
to gear up because i'm gonna be turning
stones this weekend
of course and so obviously there's so
much pressure for you to make that like
this
there's always pressure but this is like
added pressure yeah like there will be
stones in the audience friday night
turning stone casino we're going to be
turning them stones in verona new york
if you go to syracuse university it's
right by there so can't wait
to see this colgate it's right by there
now i'm remembering people at colgate
like when they were gonna get crazy and
like really special like valentine's day
with their significant other like
so every once in a while people would go
to turning stone for like a big night
or sometimes like a bunch of guys would
go and gamble but it was like a one i
never went
how far is that i i don't know but it's
far enough that you don't go often but
that you can go
right oh that's so interesting yeah i
just realized that okay maybe that's why
it's obvious you took like such a
kinship to turning stone because maybe
like
it was like a subconscious um okay so
maybe i'll have to come and i know
and i didn't realize it was turning
stone when you said that
when oh yes friday yeah okay things are
changing things are coming into
into perspective for me um it is a
gloomy friday here in new york but we
can't be stopped because tonight are the
tbj awards
it's a friday oh god it's a glitch yeah
this is crazy like yeah it's a monday
evening it is monday
it looks so monday it's so rainy outside
but our spirits can't be broken because
tonight is the tpg awards
which are always such a great night and
then tomorrow we also have tpg on the
show
to recap the tpg award so i'm excited
about that today we have the siesta key
kids
and i have much to talk to them much to
discuss we got to watch the first
episode
guys you guys it's crazy there is a
moment that is so shocking and i know
there's a lot of rumors about what's
going on in the show and you think that
this shocking moment would be about
those rumors but
it's not and i'm not i'm not even like
being paid to hype this up like
that was one of the craziest episodes of
reality television i've seen in
a really long time and it's like and
it's and it was just the premiere like
nothing even really happened they were
all just catching up but
you guys no like and i texted chloe
troutman and i was like how could you
not tell me she was like literally the
best kept secret
in reality television history and it's
so true crazy
we will get all the tea from them today
we have juliet and kelsey
robbie hayes and brandon so it'll be a
nice little crib a lot to talk to them
about
julia and kelsey like being best friends
robbie and julia doing press together
but are they still dating i don't know
i like it very interesting i can't wait
to get into it with them me too i'm
actually really excited
we're also going to recap keeping up
with the kardashians because last night
was one of the most
revolutionary episodes of reality tv in
a really long time like i don't think a
fourth wall
has ever been broken down so hard and it
was really fantasy
except on cst it was really inspiring it
was really an incredible episode and i
have
many thoughts yeah good stuff and
obviously we're going to deliver fast
five anything else how was your
what's your weekend was so [ __ ]
treacherous what
well yesterday i spent the whole day at
the apple store oh yeah which is like
you didn't even know that for my
instagram because my phone was
with the apple people the geniuses over
at apple store
by the way they run a great chip over
there but it was just like the most
frustrating day basically my phone broke
my touchscreen wasn't working and i was
like you know what this is a great
excuse i'm finally going to get the new
phone i had wanted it
so i went there and i wasn't able to get
the new phone because i needed someone
on the account
to uh follow the account to authorize it
so i
so my phone wasn't working so i was i
needed to call olivia so i asked them to
borrow their phone at the apple store
and you would think like
there's one million phones in the apple
store they give me this wartime military
phone
that i couldn't even dial the number and
they had to do it because like it was so
special it's like this is the apple
store and i can't just get a phone to
call
so i call olivia and of course she
doesn't pick up because it's a random
number i call you it doesn't even go
through
yeah so it's like okay it looks like i'm
not getting a new phone so i got my
phone repaired
and i had to wait in the area of the
apple store which is really like
touristy central and for some reason i
just looked like a giant
baby like i was wearing big chunky
sweatpants my puffer
um yeah no purse or anything and i
literally felt like kevin mcallister
home alone like roaming around new york
city with just a credit card
um so is treacherous i'm getting my
phone fixed and i guess i'll be ordering
the new phone if i ever can
just torture so once i heard about your
saga i've been talking about getting the
new phone and i was just like inspired
so um i went online and something i just
couldn't get myself
to press the button like twelve hundred
dollars i just couldn't
i mean maybe i will but i just couldn't
right now if you've seen the new camera
so i've been doing meet and greets for
like the last three weeks with people
with the new phone and it is
so much better like so much that's the
only reason like the meet and greets
have inspired me to want to get it it's
an investment in premium content so for
me
i'm ready to push the button like if
someone will let me get the new phone
yeah that's really annoying
really annoying but anyways i have my
old friend back i like her she's cool um
i wanted to share a personal update
because it has been
one entire month since i've been off my
jewel wow it's been a month since i left
morocco
left that dirty beast in my hotel room
on purpose and never looked back
happy for you thank you know that i am
good stuff
feels good i feel like my lung capacity
is definitely increasing
what i actually really feel is a lot
less anxiety and i'm thinking maybe the
jewel had something to do with it
perhaps so i'm just excited i'm excited
for you i think we should get right into
it because we have a big show yeah
we've got a lot to cover so without
further ado these are the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and yeah for sure um i don't wanna step
on anyone's toes i don't wanna like tell
you like it's not time when it is time
and it is time but
i would be i'd be so like remiss almost
devastated honestly and even heartbroken
if i didn't let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid iv
the fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated if you're trying to drink more
water liquid iv hydrates you two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone
it has an added bonus of vitamin c b3 b5
b6
and b12 they have a good give back
mission it feels good to do good liquid
iv has donated 101
1.5 million excuse me sticks to date
to places like haiti uganda puerto rico
and most recently nepal
with each person's purchase you make at
liquid iv they donate a serving to
someone in need around the world
winter is notoriously a terrible time
for dehydration if you believe it or not
a lot of people end up more dehydrated
in the winter months cold weather tends
to make us more likely to miss the signs
of dehydration and less likely to keep
refilling our water bottles
liquid iv is the easy healthy fix for
your winter dehydration
one stick of liquid iv in a 16 ounce
bottle of water
can provide two to three times the
hydration of water alone many winter
sports
take place at high altitude where it's
much easier to get dehydrated so if
you're skiing this winter season
make sure you're packing your liquid iv
it's very easily transportable
it is the fastest growing wellness brand
you can find them anywhere even at
costco their hydration multiplier is now
sold at all costco's nationwide
liquid iv products utilize cellular
transport technology and specific ratio
of glucose
sodium and potassium when mixed together
with 16 ounce water it helps your body
absorb more of the water and nutrients
you drink directly into your bloodstream
they are convenient tsa friendly powder
packets for travel and they help prevent
jet lag and altitude sickness
they fuel tough workouts help prevent
muscle fatigue promote healthy
post-workout recovery
and honestly at the end of the day
sometimes all you need is a little
hydration when you're hungover and like
what iv is just the thing that you need
so if you're taking a trip
this holiday season you're gonna be
having margaritas on the beach make sure
you're packing your liquid iv
we love it i've had it in my fridge like
literally since the day they became
sponsors and i have a constant
supply and it's really premium we know
you guys will love it too right now our
listeners can get 25
off liquidity.com when you use our code
toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order on
liquid iv's website
so go to liquidiv.com enter promo code
toast to get your savings and start
getting better hydration
that's liquidity.com promo code toast
don't wait start properly hydrating
today
sign on be hydrated sign on have to pee
more okay first story i'm sorry to start
on a down
note but it's a very sad story that
rapper juice world has died at the age
of 21.
allegedly okay juice swirl before we get
into the conspiracies
we're we're big tick tockers now and
there's a big conspiracy on tick tock
follow us girl
no job and jackie ashrae that actually
gives me hope because this is a very
very sad story terrible juice world the
rising chicago rapper who topped the
album charts in 2019 with his acclaimed
death race for love
has died at the age of 21. the rapper
born jared higgins reportedly suffered a
seizure at chicago's midway airport on
sunday
he was rushed to a nearby hospital in
extremely critical condition
where he was pronounced dead tmz first
reported the cook county medical
examiner confirmed higgins death to
rolling stone
quote the autopsy has not been performed
at this time a spokesperson for the
medical examiner said
the coroner's office later stated that
an autopsy would be performed
monday so um
he was 21 years old so sad so sad like
his career was taking off
so and the only reason i said allegedly
is because
some some things you know and i don't
want to you know sanctify
you know his life you know and be
disrespectful but
you know he did have some lyrics that
pointed to you know like maybe one day
he was gonna you know fake his own death
he tweeted that once
some of his lyrics are just like a
little ominous and i'm thinking maybe
there's more to this
there's just this tic tac that puts
together some crazy facts that will make
you believe that he faked his death
which i hope is true right he most
likely didn't that would be best case
scenario yeah that would be best case
scenario because this is so sad and so
tragic and
he had so much more life left to live do
you say scenario or scenario scenario me
too i only say scenario when i'm like
trying to be obnoxious when i'm being
fancy what are you on the toast yeah
yeah people were
being fancy with your french manicure oh
my god do you love i actually really
like it
i really like it too because when we
were growing up anytime there was a big
occasion it was like french manicure bar
mitzvah
french manicure wedding french so we
have the tbg awards tonight and i want
to be fancy i got this dress that like
kind of doesn't fit me but i'm just
going to go with it
and i was like what can distract a
french manicure no it's very
elegant thank you i feel like right now
day one while it's not chipped
it's elegant no i think if there's
nothing like there's nothing tackier in
general than like a chip manicure but
there's
really nothing worse than a chipped
french manicure 100 also people are
saying we look so snatched today by the
way people are loving the blazer
oh and i want to say why i took extra
pride in my outfit today one because the
siesta key kids are coming and they're
always snatched but two i really have
ptsd from when chris
appleton oh my god i cannot believe you
just said that because he came on the
toast the day after we got a spray tan
for the cmas and we got spray tans last
night for the tpg awards and we were
getting on a flight and
it was just like we were disheveled
clowns honestly yeah and i i think about
it all the time it's like he was
he's such a king and like we looked like
wow poppers i can't even believe you
just said that because i had such a
similar thought process this morning
because a few days
out of the month like my hair is between
like a wash and a blowout
and i don't like i didn't i'm getting my
hair done today for tbg awards i need to
do it this morning
so then i was thinking like wow the last
time that i had my hair so unkept on the
show
was chris appleton and honestly i felt
so embarrassed like i have to pull it
together so i like tried to up my outfit
a little bit and like put on a headband
that would like distract from the fact
that my hair is
in fact in a messy low bun so the chris
appleton day also scarred me and it
really affected me and it
it has impacted it i'm creating change
like it really impacted me no it really
impacted me like just because you have a
spray tan like doesn't mean you got to
look like a clown
at night like still we have a show to do
no just because you have a spray tan
does not mean you're beautiful
no oh that too i think for a while i
thought that
i thought that it meant that i was
beautiful in the summer when we come our
shorts and a t-shirt and we have a spray
tan
and you can just like have hair you
don't need that much more but in the
winter when i'm wearing i was wearing
literally a black sweater
and leggings and like an orange face and
a low bun like i don't know who i
thought i was but
she's she's gone and i'm back to being
a good i'm so i can't believe that you
said that i had such a similar like
train of thought
that's so many it really like scarred me
and chris appleton like i'm so sorry
we're not those girls no we are not
we're not those girls
okay so sad for juice world and his
family this is like a terrible
terrible tragedy and i hope we get
answers with this autopsy today
same okay next up some breaking news the
2020 golden globe nominations are here
and taylor swift is getting the respect
she deserves as is ben platt
and i just like feel like the golden
globes just happened but here we are
back
and there was no like buzz about
nominations coming out this week you
know like i just
i woke up and keltie knight was on her
instagram story at a 3 a.m call time
like talking about the nominations
right so let's go through them shall we
best actor in a limited series or tv
movie
chris abbott couch 22. cohen the spy
that actually looked good but a little
too intense for me russell crowe the
loudest voice jared harris chernobyl
winner winner winner winner sam rockwell
fosse verdin
what's so crazy is that like i consider
myself an avid tv watcher and i've never
even
heard of any of these pieces chernobyl
oh okay i've spotted
never heard of it but i've heard of
chernobyl okay best actress in a limited
tv series or tv movie whatever
caitlyn dever unbelievable oh that's i
think the netflix one
joey king the act i thought she was
already nominated no that was she was
nominated for an emmy okay the emmys and
the golden globes got to be closer
together because that feels like last
year
helen maron catherine the great merritt
weber unbelievable michelle williams
fosse verdin
i love you charity barnum and i'll give
it to you um
actually i'm gonna i'm voting for joey
king because she came on a tnn podcast
this just that's so true she supports
women owned businesses
um something about this is just kind of
making me feel left out seeing as how i
guess i really don't watch tv i watch
mostly reality tv
and i do really wish there was like a
serious award ceremony like honestly
when people really open up on television
and like are genuine and authentic like
and you know everyone goes through their
seasons of like where they're really
open and where they're going through
things publicly like
i think that's admirable and i honestly
feel like at some point in time like
teresa judas deserves an award like
people who really open themselves up and
like give everything to their craft i
totally agree that there needs to be a
serious
yeah not a people's choice award and not
like a fan voted
there are so there's like a reality tv
award show i think it's called the
reality tv award show and that's just
not cutting it like we need like
the the realsies yeah like the oscars of
reality television yeah i totally agree
best tv movie or limited series catch 22
chernobyl fosse verdin the loudest voice
unbelievable
sounds like it's literally the same five
shows yeah but now best tv series comedy
barry flee bag the kaminsky method
marvelous mrs maisel the politician
justice for the politician
except i think fleabag will win because
they sweep the emmys yeah but marvelous
miss basil like sweeps everything always
they're like the um
slumdog millionaire that's true best
original score uh little women
joker marriage story 1917 motherless
brooklyn haven't seen any oh right
this is movies and tv yeah best original
song
beautiful ghost cats so i'll dance with
these beautiful
i'm gonna love me again from rocket man
they had a whole slew of songs they had
to write an original yeah i was gonna
say i don't know that one i can't
perform it
into the unknown from frozen two
spirit from the lion king stand up
harriet wow this is some stiff
competition you see
versus taylor swift beyonce versus
taylor swift versus panic at the disco
oh panic at the disco they might just
come right in there well have fun for
taylor like her friends just like
nominated for golden globes
but usually there's a clear front runner
for best original song this is actually
going to be really tough and
i don't i kind of am team spirit
from lion king which song is that oh
spirit
when um simba and nala are running back
to the right rock that was inspiring but
i mean obviously like i stan taylor and
that song is so good
and like she got to make it with andrew
lloyd webber who like i actually learned
about in college like he's so
legendary um so obviously if i had a
vote i would give it to her
okay this next category best supporting
actress in a series limited series or tv
movie
meryl streep big little eyes okay helena
bottom carter the crown i need to talk
about this in one second
emily watson chernobyl patricia arquette
the act tony collette unbelievable
okay um first of all the crown came out
last week so i can't believe they're
already up for
awards like with the grammys you have to
release it a year ago in order to be up
for it
and second of all controversial
statement i didn't love helena bottom
carter in the crown but maybe because i
just don't like princess margaret
by the way i finished the crown
incredible it wasn't the best season
they've ever done but it was just so
interesting
and they're really setting it up spoiler
to like make the argument that charles
is not fit to rule
shook shook they're being like kind of
heavy-handed about it
um it seems like that show unbelievable
on netflix oh wait
i'm thinking of insatiable on netflix
i'm like debbie ryan's gonna be
nominated
what's unbelievable unbelievable i think
it's i believe
it's the one about the girl um
who was raped and then it's about her
trial and just assessing the fact sounds
good
yeah it looks good best actor in a tv
series comedy michael douglas the
kaminsky method
bill hader barry ben platt the
politician paul rudd living with
yourself
rami yusef rami well what a star-studded
category
i'm really pulling for ben platt first
time winner first time nominee love him
so much
really support it's also the only show
i've ever seen on that list
the sad thing about the golden globes is
they don't really matter because not
only doesn't contribute towards egot
yeah but it does like set the tone for
the office that's what they say
best actress in a tv series comedy
christina applegate dead to me
oh by the way i forgot about dead to me
when is it coming back hopefully soon
really good show phoebe waller bridge
flea bag natasha leone russian doll
kiersten dunst i'm becoming a god in
central florida rachel brosnahan
the marvelous mrs nasal that's a funny
name for a show
that is i love kirsten dunst but i
assume it's going to go to phoebe waller
i think the weirdest flex of our
generation is that kirsten dunst
um ended up with the guy from friday
night lights landry
yeah you know who was in the irishman
who yeah like they're both
weirdly in a lot of like important
cinema he was also like weirdly only in
the last three episodes of breaking bad
remember he was like that white
nationalist i never saw it oh um
he just keeps showing up he actually
gets good work he was in the irishman
yeah
he was a guy's son best actor in a tv
series drama
brian cox secession kit harrington game
of thrones
rami malik mr robot tobiah menzies the
crown oh i wonder who he played maybe
prince philip he really had a glow up
this year
billy porter pose um interesting that
only one of the game of thrones guys was
nominated who else would have been
eligible for that category who didn't
die
oh yeah and he was the only one he's won
the emmy
into her son but it really was like the
jon snow year
yeah and actually there were a bunch of
episodes that peter dinklage wasn't even
in i feel like
people are over game of thrones yeah i
mean
it's it's weird that we're now like
giving nominations for the crown which
came out a week ago and game of thrones
which ended like a year ago it's like
how is that the same year
yeah it's weird best screenplay marriage
story
parasite the two popes once upon a time
in hollywood and the irishman
woof woof best actress in a tv series
drama jennifer aniston the morning show
congrats
olivia coleman the crown doing an
incredible job jody comer killing eve
nicole kidman big little lies reese
witherspoon the morning show
i would take any of these yeah me too
it's funny that reece witherspoon like
would have been eligible for two shows
you know because she just kills it
because she's in big little eyes
and the morning show true best
supporting are they still doing big
little lies as
a like a mini series or whatever it had
two
i started the second season with meryl
streep but like honestly
i am not into meryl streep's vibe like i
used to really like her when she was
just doing like nancy myers movies
um but something about her like i really
don't like her anymore and i find her
like to be triggering and her presence
like ruins things for me and she was
like ruining big little eyes so i just
stopped big little lie season two wasn't
good because all they did was talk about
what happened in season one and season
one was great because of the way that it
ended and you feel like it's a happily
ever after but then season two just goes
to show you
pittsville it was a perfect format and
the way that season two ended is maybe
the way that season one should have
ended like they did the thing and then
i don't know how it ends they did the
thing they did the thing that's it i'm
just i'm over it
great best supporting actress in a
motion picture
this is notable because jennifer lopez
is nominated for hustlers oh great did
you
see jennifer lopez on snl and i would
love to know i love bits and pieces i
haven't seen the whole episode me too i
did like youtube
um clips i i was really like uh let down
by her monologue like it was really
awkward
i was let down by the fact that she wore
the dress again yeah it's like so silly
but whatever she looked great and
honestly like
anytime i could just see her thighs up
close and high def like i wasn't mad
but i was just like let down kind of by
the writing i thought she did a decent
job
i think that she flubbed her words the
first sentence with the first joke and
it just like
she never got her footing back um and
then i thought the skits were so
incredibly stupid the ones that i saw at
least
i just um i wasn't inspired and i've
been really liking snl like these last
couple weeks i think they've had great
skits like the will ferrell
episode was really great so i was just a
little let down interesting
did you see the hoops sketch yes that
was funny the funny part was
that you can get them to say daddy's
little girl or daddy's big [ __ ]
okay best actor in a motion picture
musical or comedy daniel craig knives
out that movie looks good
roman griffin davis jojo rabbit leonardo
dicaprio once upon a time in hollywood
taryn egerton rocket man eddie murphy
dolomite is my name
honestly give it to taran egerton yeah
he's such a star
best animated picture how to train your
dragon the lion king missing link toy
story four frozen two lion king good
bye but frozen two it's like breaking
every single record oh is it mm-hmm
i don't really like i i'm i'm happy with
frozen one you know
yeah oh wow best actress in emotion
picture musical or comedy aquafina
anna j armas what is goldstein emma
thompson can't blanch it
wait i don't know aquafina is uh they
didn't say ocean's 11
that's like oh crazy rich asians when
that was last year they didn't say what
it was and what about beanie field team
probably book smart yeah
so i started book smart and it was so
funny did you see the controversy about
delta
no so um you know when you watch a movie
on a plane like it's always
censored like a little bit either with
curse words like sex scenes but they
took out
um pretty much every like lesbian
reference in book smart and like delta
got
so much heat for it when they came out
they were like we use a third party
company that just like selects movies
for us and edits them and we're really
sorry and they put it back the normal
way
but then i watched book smart like on a
delta flight and i was like i wonder if
i'm only seeing half the movie like have
they updated it yet
and i didn't finish it it was very cute
people were like you're gonna love it
you are bd falcon it's like no [ __ ]
we're both just chubby like she was a
nerd like
and who didn't even want to like drink
like that we're the opposite like we're
gonna be less
similar we're just both chubby and
burdette and jewish like we are
different
okay um it was it was a good movie
though i need to finish it and i like
the girl who played the other girl i
thought she was a cute like new star on
the scene yeah she reminded me of k
pandavaker from the disney days yes
i believe she's an unbelievable got it
best tv series drama big little lies
okay so it's being considered a series
now good
the crown yes killing eve the morning
show succession
so i know like succession is just fake
dynasty
these um nominations are like really
making me realize how there's like
nothing
out there you know it's like you scroll
netflix you scroll disney plus
and you think like there's just so much
content out there because the streaming
wars make us think that but at the end
of the day there's like really nothing
to watch
there's nothing on here that i feel like
fomo from not watching no there's
nothing on here that's like oh i've been
meaning to watch that i know i would
love it maybe i need to start reading
books or something
i think that you should i think that i
should too and i have a recommendation
actually
for a book that i heard about that is
shaking the world
can you tell me to its core are you as
bored of netflix as we are have you
binged your way through disney plus
already and now have nothing new and
exciting to entertain you
we have a solution for you it's a brand
new book called the band of shadows
even better i heard a rumor that the
writer the author
is a toaster so obviously she has good
taste
good style um if you're into the
descendants we know you are jackie harry
potter
twilight a true favorite or the hunger
games you're going to love this book it
is a young adult fantasy fiction but
it's also so much more
it's a story of friendship adventure
mystery and intrigue with a dash of
romance and comedy thrown in there
plus the cover is seriously steamy vibes
almost a little
plenty like a dark plain the book
follows 17
year old scarlett pierce a seemingly
normal girl who was thrust into a
mystical world of avalon and told she
belongs to a powerful race of people
known as faze
for the first time in her life scarlett
feels like she belongs but the truth
isn't always what it seems
soon scarlet discovers that a war is
brewing and that the reason she was
brought to avalon is far more
mind-blowing than she could have ever
imagined
when the war finally arrives scarlet
will make a shocking discovery about her
past
from the most unlikely sources and
everything she has ever known will be
thrown into consequence
grab a copy you guys we got a big winter
break coming up
there's nothing for you to watch on tv
anymore expand your horizons
with band of shadows you can actually
ask the author in any of the toaster
book clubs
um she's in a mall so if you've got any
questions for the author you gotta check
her out
she uh grab a copy snuggle up in the
cold weather with some tea or maybe a
giant glass of wine and read band of
shadows
you can buy band of shadows on amazon
with code toasters for 10 off
that's band of shadows by hp wait on
amazon with the code
toasters for 10 off support your local
toaster guys and
maybe expand your vocabulary because you
know it's been a minute since i wrote a
book
love it okay two more categories that
are just interesting this is the movie
of the year
uh best motion picture musical or comedy
once upon a time in hollywood
jojo rabbit knives out rock man dolomite
is my name
jojo siwa jojo c was nominated thank god
best motion picture drama this is like
the
category the irishman marriage story
1917
joker the two popes the joker should win
i i mean i've only irishman wins i'll be
annoyed of course but it's the only one
of these that i've seen which means i
have to see at least one more marriage
story
that's the one with scarlett johansson
and adam driver where they're like
getting a divorce
i never even heard of it it's like you
think i'm such like i do
my job is being a pop culture analyst
i've never heard of any of these things
am i doing a bad job i don't know or do
i just have taste
best actress and emotion picture drama i
feel like some of these movies haven't
even come out yet
cynthia or evo harriet scarlett
johansson marriage story schwarze ronin
little women that didn't even come out
yet i keep seeing commercials her name
is cersei ronan
i think it's smart no it's sercia okay
charlize throne bombshell didn't come
out yet and renee zellweger
judy i am looking forward to bombshell
though that commercial with all the
women in the elevator
shocking chunk i'm really excited but
anyways i haven't seen these things yet
it's too
soon it's too early go back to sleep
golden globes
okay you ready for our next story yes
because cardi b gets a lap dance and
makes it rain in nigerian strip club
this was what a what a journey to be on
these instagram stories
yes cardi b took to instagram well she
went to a nigerian strip club this
weekend for her show
there she went in advance and her show
wasn't at the strip club
then she posted all of these stories to
instagram that just took the world by
story she went out to the club and the
club happened to be a strip club she had
so much cash i'm sure like the
conversion helped with how many bills
she got
yeah because they were 200 bills yes and
uh
in the toasters they had uh done them
said that they are basically like 50
cents converted
to u.s dollars but the cost of goods in
nigeria is different so like
that bill can get you they were saying
like a ride on mta
oh you know and that's like three
dollars here right so it's not totally
equivalent but they weren't two hundred
dollar bills she was being very generous
though
yes um and it was actually crazy i don't
know if the instagram stories ended up
get getting taken down because
just based on instagram like policy like
they were completely illegal like i saw
nipple i saw vagina i actually saw a
[ __ ] piercing like it was very
when did you watch um i watched when i
saw it someone posted about it in the
toasters so
i think i saw the whole thing i don't
think i saw the whole thing because i
only saw
booty i did not see vagine i did not see
nipples so i think instagram deleted the
ones
that um were like were anything other
than ass
because instagram is pro ass they are
pro asp as long as it's wearing
a thong no i don't even think you need
to be wearing a thong oh really
yeah they're just anti-nip and
antivision so
anti-nip yeah um and there was like a
hole posted the toasters about and
people were getting really heated about
whether or not like they should be
allowed
on social media like it was a real it
was a conversation being had between
parents because some parents were like
i have a young boy it's like i don't
want them seeing this and then someone
else was like i have a young boy too and
he has pornhub so like what's the
difference you know right
um i don't really care i love that cardi
b gives back to this
stripper community she's a proud
ex-stripper like one lanithia leaks
and i love that she's giving back to her
community i just hope she got everyone's
permission that's what i was oh i'm sure
she did everyone looked like they were
having the best time the crowd was
having so much
like you have to keep in mind like these
people are being paid to look like
they're having fun so just want to make
sure they knew and they were okay with
their clits being on instagram
with someone who has 30 million
followers i i i'm gonna assume that
everyone was okay with it i'm gonna swim
too because everyone was filming
and it's not like he was like sneaky
filming like the girl was dancing for
the camera
yeah and i'm sure they could have just
not participated if they didn't want to
i thought it was just like a really fun
way to wake up on sunday morning even
though i didn't get the whole shebang
i yeah i didn't get all day but i guess
i got the full
month but like the way that i saw it was
the way that was like acceptable for
social media
and it was just like fun you know yeah
young kids shouldn't be watching that
but
right and then there was a lot of talk
about the fact that she's a pepsi
ambassador and they're like notoriously
corporate and it's like that is that a
pepsi ambassador should be behaving but
it's like you knew who you were hiring
when you were pretty big
i know i know she's unapologetically
herself and honestly i'd be really
disappointed in pepsi if they like
pulled her
commercial or something because her
commercial is so funny give the gift of
cash
she's hilarious yeah i love that she is
who she is she's never pretended to be
anyone else when people are shocked by
this it's like what did you think that
she was a nun
yeah totally so i'm glad she had a good
time she was making it great and whoever
looked like they were having a good time
was in charge of documenting her
instagram story like worked really hard
that night yeah they should be a
documentarian yeah he was getting all
the angles i assume it was a he because
he
no it's definitely he he was like
what i feel like it was a she oh really
i think i heard a man's voice if it was
a he
but there were men all around like she
world with a big crew
i guess looks like a serious strip club
like
top-tier luxurious rich good stuff
okay speaking of only for the best men
in nigeria speaking of premium videos
kylie jenner's daughter stormy has
learned how to snowboard and she's
taking the world by story and she's
taking the world by
story with the best video i've ever seen
in my life
of her snowboarding down like a little
bunny hill giving zero [ __ ] she was
going kind of fast
crushing it stormy is like the athlete
of our generation did you see her
shooting hoops she's a jenner
i know she's got that bruce jenner
triathlon blood also i picked this story
because i just want to talk about like
kylie's looks
where is she i don't know i was like
trying to find out and i was looking at
all these people's
um stories and tagged photos but stos is
not there
her friend iris is which maybe makes me
think it's just like a kid's trip
because iris has kids
so it's a family trip it's not like a
fun girls trip so i didn't know who else
was there i can't find any information
on where she is
her whole fendi ski look was so like
shook worthy it was not fair
her whole table of chanel accessories
like
choking choking did you see a report
that said kylie jenner spends half a
million dollars a month on security
half a mil that seems decent that's
six million dollars a year that's
actually not bad and it's an expense
right
yeah i mean she needs like serious
security now can you imagine like
very publicly posting that you're
somewhere snowing and nobody knows where
you are
crazy crazy she's like on a private
mountain or something yeah i don't know
but this video started me first of all
like
she's a better skier than all of us
stormy is a memester
between rise and shine this her
basketball layup like she's
she's turning into it like the world's
best content creator that basketball
video like
kills me every single time because every
time i watch it i'm like is she gonna
hit that no when you first thought it's
like why is this video going viral like
nothing is happening so obviously she
makes the hoop like that's why it's
gone so viral no but it's like not even
close rise and shine
oh my god i love this kid i love these
videos kylie thank you for this premium
content like
we are not worthy yeah i thought when
kylie had a baby that she would be kind
of like kim was in the beginning with
north like very protective
not on camera all the girls in the
beginning courtney too like didn't
really want to film like the kids faces
when they were young but kylie's been
very open which is
surprising because she's not even on the
show yeah we'll get to the show
after the show after this fifth and
final story because speaking of
olympic level snowboarders speaking of
olympic level snowboarders
uh russia has been banned from all
global sports including the 2020
olympics
and the 2022 world cup finals because of
their doping
russia is crazy like they gotta stop
always something with
russia i'm so embarrassed i'm an eastern
european jew these are my people
technically i mean theo he's quaking oh
my god he can't perfect
no he's american citizen so he actually
can um play on team america no of course
but like it's just humiliating
it's humiliating and they're always just
like being so shady like honestly like
the russians have the worst reputation
in the u.n right now like i'd be so
embarrassed
it's like if the human was a high school
like the
you know the russians would be the only
school this isn't even political this is
just like
and by the way but i'm at the united
nations russian athletes crush it like
they don't even need to dope i just i
don't understand they're like the home
school jungle freaks
100 the world anti-doping agency has
imposed a four-year ban on russia from
all global is the world anti-doping
agency the water
yeah wow that actually is i love an
acronym wada's executive committee took
the decision after concluding moscow had
tampered with laboratory data wow
like not only are they doping they're
like faking samples spies kgb
um they're gonna appeal the decision
they have 21 days to do so
uh this is just like dodgeball with
bernice this is [ __ ] crazy she was
taking steroids god damn it bernice
i just like i don't know they're they're
such great athletes they have such great
gymnasts they have such great ski
conditions like they can do it all so
just [ __ ] play
you know what i can't really judge them
because earlier this year i had strep
throat and i took steroids prednisone
and i definitely almost got addicted
like i love the way steroids make me
feel they were so
um empowering
that i totally understand the russians
and maybe it's the maybe it's the little
bit of russian in me that totally
understands the doping
yeah i love i love roy's i was write it
up earlier this year
i can't wait to get my hands on another
prednisone z pack it was so
so lit i'm happy for you um should we
recap the kardashians is that a fifth
and final story okay
what an insane episode of keeping up
with the kardashians
i cannot believe when they were showing
promise for the episode and they were
like reading their q scores and like
their audience feedback i thought that
was kind of revolutionary i didn't
realize the whole episode was going to
be
about scheduling and filming and i am
1000
on courtney and kim's i mean sorry on
kim and chloe's side
and i was really like taking a step back
and thinking like this at the end of the
day and i was watching the episode being
like i cannot wait to recap this on the
toast because i have so many thoughts at
the end of the day
there's really just two different types
of people in this world and
i feel like i'm definitely more of a kim
and chloe like a much more tough love
much more like whatever you're going
through get over it and move on like
there's work to do
and so while i'm all sympathetic towards
courtney's
boundaries it does seem like for someone
who doesn't work
she has a lot of boundaries and it's
hard for me to like relate to her on
that level because like
the one job that she has she can no
longer do and it's just like a level of
entitlement i can't relate to
here's the thing she made no [ __ ]
sense because she was like i have things
going on in my life other than the show
and it's like you can't make that
argument when you're sitting in the same
room as kim kardashian west who's
studying to be a lawyer who's going to
the white house who's getting people out
of jail who has a beauty company who has
a fragrance company who has a shapewear
line
who has more kids than you yeah so that
argument holds absolutely no water no
but what she was saying was that she has
boundaries of things she doesn't want to
film
and then chloe and kim were like well we
need you to film these things
like your boyfriend she's like well i
don't have a boyfriend so what other
things are you doing that you don't want
to feel right making dinner with
khadijah
if you're not dating you don't have a
boyfriend what are you doing at night
like where where are you going and why
can't we follow you
no it's so it was such a frustrating
episode and i was really surprised
at kris jenner for being on the wrong
side of history like she
created this show she steered it to
success and now she's just really taking
a step back and it's like at the end of
the day
not only can chloe and kim not put on
the whole show like
every season every year 60 minutes like
it's a lot the audience wants to see
everyone like we already don't have
kendall and kylie because
chloe actually was answering questions
on twitter and they were like why aren't
you guys bringing kendall and kylie into
this
and they were like well ken and kylie
have different contracts courtney kim
and i are equals i guess they're the
three
main characters who get paid the most
that's pretty much what it meant and
then it really got me thinking like
honestly i also think it's not fair that
chloe and kendall
i mean that kendall and kylie just get
to skate by like at the end of the day
as much as nobody wants to admit this
kylie is where she is um billionaire
business mogul
and kendall is where she is being the
number one paid model in the world
without ever really having any
experience getting started
because of this show and you have to pay
it back
i don't even think it's fair that
kendall and kylie don't have to film
like i think all five of them should be
working equally like
kim literally and all they do now is
like sit in their house on their phones
and scroll and film a scene and call it
tv when like it's not
yeah no i totally agree i think kendall
and kylie i understand why they're not
main people but they should be in every
episode at least once and they should be
giving it back because the show is the
mothership and without the show
they lose like with the show they're
able to change the narrative yes it's
like six months later
but we're able to see everything from
their side and their beloved because of
it where whereas like if we're only just
reading tmz headlines like
we don't get to know them and we don't
sympathize i mean i always do
but like everyone else like even with
jordan when chloe started tweeting at
jordan like days after she was cheated
on like she's the villain
yeah then you watch it all play back and
you see chloe find out that jordan's
going on red table talk but she doesn't
even apologize and it's like
oh now we see what's really going on
it's the nucleus of
their brand and it has to work and a
part of me was watching the episode
really like being in fear of like maybe
this is them like
getting us prepared for the show and i'm
not prepared i'm not prepared and i'm
not okay with it and like honestly i
don't really
care that courtney is not gonna film
anymore i think like the fact that she's
so
she won't budge she's so unreasonable
and even if she was sharing like things
that we wanted her to share like i don't
really care for her like i'm okay with
her not being on the show
but now the more that i think about it
like chris is out candles out kylie's
out rob is out it's like it's literally
just like
scott kim and chloe and like that does
not that's not enough
and jonathan and like and that's kind of
right so four out of six of the main
characters are paid to be there as like
extras basically yeah
so it's just it's not gonna work forever
and
it's a problem and it feels like nobody
understands that it's a problem except
for kim and chloe yeah no they're
they're 100 right it was a crazy crazy
thing to watch and now
we know that courtney is taking a step
back and i hope that what they're saying
is like
don't do the show you're not going to
get paid right now i wanted to hear
about the money because it's not they're
not going to talk about the money
because at the end of the day their
family
and there are certain things that like
lines that they don't cross and they're
not going to start being petty with each
other talking about money
so i get that but i think when they said
fired that means money right and i so i
just want to be
like clear that's we're talking about
the money here yeah but it's also
talking about the content and the
livelihood of the show and when they had
production in that
um meeting and the producer was like
actively part of the conversation one i
thought that was just such a great way
to film it
and two it's it's easy to just dismiss
things as when you're courtney just
hearing it from kim because she thinks
kim's always on her ass but hearing your
boss like your producer
the person in charge of putting the
content together telling you like you
don't open up and like we
we asked you if we could go film you
having dinner with khadija and you say
no like
that is more real right and courtney
being like
i can't do it because i have three
parent-teacher conferences in one week
in one week
in one week and then her getting up in
the middle of that conversation which
was
on its way to being productive obviously
like it was an uncomfortable
conversation and
when family fights it's always awkward
and people's feelings get hurt but her
just like getting up in the middle and
taking her mic off like that's the exact
point it's like you don't
want to see anything through yeah like
let's just finish this conversation it's
torture but like let's finish it
and now it doesn't make sense to me like
they're doing all i mean i'm sure they
have a big partnership with quibby but
they're going to do all these offshoot
shows and it's like no we need all that
content for the mainstream you need all
that energy
kendall if she's gonna do anything we
need it on the main show yeah the
the final episode i didn't realize next
week was the c-season finale it looks
incredible mm-hmm incredible like
first of all i cannot but you see their
life in wyoming like obviously kim and
kanye have been spending a lot of time
there
um the families all together which they
really haven't been in a really long
time with kendall and kylie
um and i think when they're all together
the dynamics definitely shift because
courtney feels more empowered to speak
her mind because kendall supports her
yeah and when she's with chloe and kim
like nobody really empowers her to speak
up
so it'll be a really good episode yeah
where they obviously come to the
resolution that courtney's going to take
a step back but they need to figure out
what are they going to show us instead
honestly i would watch a show all about
kim and chloe happily because they're my
two favorites but we just need a little
more like even when he was she was
meeting with the
former prisoner who had these tattoos
like we i'm sure she has tons of stories
like oh my god by the way if we just got
a show about kim and her businesses like
that would be enough for me dying right
like kim
just sitting getting her hair and makeup
done just talking and scrolling on her
phone like that would be enough for me
diane
i just don't want someone else to get
paid for her doing that right but that's
what kim said at the very end at the end
of the day i just want it to be fair
it's not fair um just really quick
sidebar when she met with that guy and
he brought her flowers like that was so
incredibly cute it was so cute by the
way
kanye in the car was being so funny and
kim wasn't even giving him any attention
no i feel like she's just like used to
him and you know i'm sure people are
like ben so funny
the make-a-wish thing when he was
talking you have that guy
named all those other people and was
like but you
you know i thought that's something
funny and it was really interesting
right after she had read the feedback
of people saying that she doesn't open
up with kanye enough and i actually felt
like
she's been doing a fine job of it like
as a consumer and a watcher of the show
i don't feel like
we get no kanye i just feel like i wish
we got more but i'm happy with the
amount that we get 100
and i feel like at this junction in time
uh kanye opens up to the show
more than courtney does yes and um kanye
like doesn't owe us anything nope this
isn't his show courtney owes us
everything um but i'm just gonna think
at this point she's muddied the waters i
don't even wanna
i don't even wanna i just couldn't get
over the flowers i thought it was so
incredibly cute do you think they were
from books 100
this is short and quality for bootcats
b-o-u-q-s
bouquets did i just say oh man bouquets
oh man i'm mortified
um books is a floral company we've
spoken about many times on this show i
think the best part of it is that they
come from eco-friendly farmers
who pay their workers higher on average
and have high standards for quality and
freshness
they're effortlessly styled that
perfectly grace any space
and they have a happiness guarantee the
boost company wants to make sure you
love your flowers and have a great
experience
um but now for the holiday season
they're offering wreaths
fresh flowers obviously plants and gifts
and they start at just 39
they even have flower subscription
service which is perfect for the hull
for a holiday gift
brings happiness to anyone and you can
save money every time they have
nationwide
and next slash same day delivery which
is amazing it is ideal for holidays
birthdays thank yous or
just because they are sustainably grown
flowers cut fresh from the world's
finest eco-friendly farms
because their flowers are sourced
directly they stay fresher longer
and you're not paying a crazy price um
to have someone send flowers because at
the end of the day
sending some flowers like kim looks like
so like humbled by those flowers
it should be easier and better quality
and less expensive and boost is helping
you get there yeah it shouldn't be so
hard
um and all we want for chrismaka is
books it is short for bouquet b-o-u-q-s
fresh-cut from the world's finest farms
you can get 25
off by going to books.com toast and
using the promo code toast at checkout
so that's b-o-u-q-s
dot com toast use the promo code toast
at checkout
um we'll be right book see what i did
there oh yeah we will be right book we
are bringing out the cast of siesta key
let's go i can't wait a second longer
soon
so
we are back with four out of like eight
of the siesta key members we are
so excited to be here sitting down with
them we got to watch the first episode
of season three last night
and we're not trying to rub it in and
talk about it too much because it
doesn't premiere until january 7th but
it was
so good so thank you guys again for
putting together a premium slate of
content for us people have been waiting
so long for season three now it's been
almost a year
i know crazy torture is when the last
episode aired wow
wow so when did you start filming season
three april april
oh my god you guys just don't stop like
apparently
you are watching it is it so annoying to
like relive
um those moments yeah it's not like
annoying it's just like okay can i move
on with my life before
right about something you're like oh i
did that yeah i said that
totally but and also relationships
always change in the key
like best friends and boyfriends until
like to go back
like that might have been three fights
ago right things are so different
and so much has happened and this week
was announced that robbie is joining the
cast i mean
i think a lot of people thought that
right thank you robbie for for doing the
lord's work
people had pretty much guessed that
since we knew that you two had been
dating on social media you took the
trip to greece together very cute
premium content with the drone we really
enjoyed it
i love it um but now you're here
and i'm pretty sure you're not together
right we're not together so is that
weird now like doing press like you know
promoting the show and
it's gotten better okay
yeah we've like seen each other a couple
times since everything's happened
so we're fine you're from jacksonville
florida is that close to siesta
um five hours right no three and a half
so how do you know alex or dude
my first job out of college was i was
relocated to sarasota siesta key
so i lived there for five years from 22
to 27. oh what do you mean
that's why i moved away did that have
anything to do with you guys connecting
like and sorry no it was through kelsey
i knew brandon beforehand
yeah i didn't really know these two um i
had talked to juliette before
on social media through a fundraiser
that she helped out with from my old
leisurelytics company and then i worked
with kelsey i took her on one of my
agency's trip or bella in january to
thailand
and then we all went to stagecoach
together it always starts at stage
every time that's what led into filming
that month it really did start at
stagecoach
it's like one of those weekend oh i just
love it they're just so much fun
it's so much fun was that where you guys
first started dating yes
yes that's yes and how long did you just
find like a month and a half
oh so are you taking for the whole
season coming up or no
like maybe like half can we say that oh
okay
i think probably what's most exciting to
me is we
saw you guys finish last season then we
watched you on social media for
eight months right and now we're
re-watching and you two are best friends
yes
and you live together yes how did that
happen and we're here for it i think
women supporting women like it clicked
and i think we both like
got out of relationships and started
traveling together everywhere
and i think we just like yeah we just
like put our [ __ ] aside like yeah
we're just like
it's always been about guys in the past
and finally like there was no guys in
our life
you know what like this is stupid and
you can always kind of tell like your
compatibility with someone
when you live together and we never
really fight like ever do you still live
together
yeah it's been like a while it's been
like seven or eight years now
and it's going well yeah it's going
great and how about you brandon
talk to me about you last time we saw
you you were recording a music video
yeah yeah
and are you still doing music you cut
your hair yeah yeah i am i'm just still
doing music doing a bunch of different
things
i did cut my hair yeah it was long like
it was i had the bun you know i cut it
off different look now yeah
do you feel different without a man bun
i do feel different you know i sort of
acted for now without a mistake
with the man but it was more like hippie
like cool
yeah it's more like business
yeah that's what i was gonna say i just
couldn't think of the biblical reference
but you still have your strengths
exactly i said my strengths so you guys
get a lot of new cast members obviously
robbie is new this season
we have carol who's gone from last
season and who's joining that's news
and when is jared like gonna get his due
diligence as a full-time cast member
fans yeah a lot of people love to i mean
i love you he's an american hero
jared's still around obviously no more
canvas um
what about paige
no carson no person car sits out here
randomly pops up yeah he randomly comes
around so obviously chloe's still
going to be yelling at everyone yeah
what else would she be amazing i love
her amanda yeah yeah i think also such a
weird flex by you guys like amanda brook
chloe's nose and like here they are
being best friends yelling at robbie at
the pool party like it doesn't make a
goddess this way
anything can happen in the key yeah yeah
we have like issues for sure
and we don't see alex he's on a trip
yeah flying private home he comes back
next week we see that
uh yeah and kara is flying private as
well
um probably not yes yeah
i was like i don't know if new jersey
money is private plane money yeah no
it's not
she she comes she comes out of this
season she's come swinging she's not in
a good mood she's really
like really like hungry all the time or
something like that
she's just like always [ __ ] she's
growing on me
no she she i was really not liking her
this episode she was being like super
mean
i can't wait to hear what she said she's
just a brat like you're i am well she
kind of i don't like her
you two have a lot of history i don't
even know why you guys don't like each
other but it's almost like last season
you
you both said things about each other
and then you watched it and then
this season you're like mad at each
other about things you guys said about
each other from last season
for us yeah like it plays a part in the
um well i always
say like the cameras really are like a
whole other character in themselves
like they really are like when you know
that you're like being filmed
it makes a difference for sure and then
you hear what people say behind the show
has definitely made a difference
a big difference i'm going to take some
questions from instagram this is from
mckeely noel
is it hard to keep everything on the dl
as things play out because of the show
and what you can share on social media
what you can't share
yeah i mean we kind of know what we have
to do though at this point it's like
your life and you want to share it with
everyone because that's what you're used
to
being on social media yeah yeah you just
kind of have to suck it up even though
you want to like complain to everyone
about it it's worth it currently going
on
right and you have to know what you can
post right um from jb12 are we gonna see
juliet's gal pals like hannah this
season i always want more of your like
tallahassee friends
yeah they're so cute you see hannah like
a couple times
oh yeah yeah we have a trip to nashville
and that's where hannah lives now
so she's gonna see her there she just
like randomly pops up and everyone's
like wait what
she's back we had gotten a question do
you guys think you would ever do a
season where like you're all on a trip
like in a house
i would love to i'm over it would be
being in the town i grew up in like
right and what are the people in siesta
key like the natives think of the show
um they're back and forth yeah yeah i
think it's gonna be better it's a great
it's great here for the show
for the commercial so beautiful it's so
beautiful and but they like give us
dirty looks and stuff and i'm just
saying
do you mind or they like your mama's
right in front of us
yeah we filmed that scene where they
literally kicked us off the beach oh my
god
there was over here yeah we did where
serious conversation and this lady is
like screaming at us we're like
sitting on the rocks behind her on the
beach
and she's like screaming like this we
had to stop probably they wouldn't let
us finish it yeah i don't know yeah
when were you living in siesta key
yes i lived there all summer for three
months and what about now not now i'm
back in l.a got it okay what was that
like did you like living in chesapeake
yeah i mean i had lived there for five
years it's going from one beautiful
beach in venice to you know probably the
east coast most beautiful beach wasn't
hard
right i had a bunch of great people
around me so so you're no stranger to
reality tv how
was being on siesta key like different
than bachelor
yeah it was different i just mentioned
that earlier this morning you know
you're not a contestant anymore you're
you're building something that you know
could be one season could be three
seasons could be seven seasons who knows
right so it's it's really
i'm one of those guys that puts it all
out there right wear it on my sleeve if
you've seen it in
past tv shows so it it works it's
something that i like i enjoy it i feel
like a lot of people have like
preconceived like notions about you and
people are really like judgy about you
even in the first episode like how does
that affect you
it must be [ __ ] annoying it doesn't
really affect me but it does affect my
mom which affects me
my mom will go through every comment all
500 to thousand of them
hey britney xoxo said that you're like
the leader i'm like mom chill
like oh my god wait i read the funniest
comment on your um
post though toasters are [ __ ] robbie
bees because he's like really thirsty
stay
even in the first episode where you're
talking to chloe about like your
intentions and you're saying like really
all the right things
and she's still stuck and she's just you
might see yeah it might be a theme
throughout
yeah other guys on the show say the
absolute worst thing is
and then you're like but they're great
you know what it's like if everyone is
like talking about alex how he treated
you last season
yeah and then it's like but they're done
now so it's like that doesn't mean that
he didn't say those mean things to you
like he still said it right
yeah i'm speaking of alex it's a
question from nina
loosen louis um is alex affiliated with
the season he hasn't posted anything on
his instagram about the new season and
he's barely in the teaser
well he complains constantly about how
much he hates it because it makes him
look bad but then he like still does the
show so
alex doesn't really post a lot on social
media either okay
yeah he gives us more to himself
paul's on this season yeah he's on the
seasons
i feel really strongly that he should no
not self-destructive he's destructive
he's a tornado oh well yeah he takes
down everything in his
path and i feel really strongly that he
should not be compensated
on the show i think it empowers him to
uh his bad behavior yeah right
i mean that's just paul after the second
night is when he starts to do it
yeah the first day he just needs to get
off live
but then like amazing things happen and
like his microphone doesn't turn on
during his performances
a lot of karma comes to fall for sure
so when we when we open this season you
and alex are not together
um can you talk a little bit about the
dissolution of that relationship because
it was so much a part of last season
right well so i guess him and i like
officially broke up in
like march and that was a huge thing for
us we were both like trying to get over
each other in our own ways i was off
traveling
he was at strip clubs stuff like that
and
it kind of and he was like [ __ ] i can't
be around you
blah blah blah and then he hears that
robbie's coming on the show and he's
like oh hell no
and then like flies back on his private
plate and
it's just like yeah alex and i are both
like it feels like with alex and it's
like
you do this then i do that then i'm
going to do this and you're going to do
that it's just like one thing after that
gets worse and worse it just keeps
getting worse but so since you broke up
you haven't gotten back together
no that's great no yeah i think that's
good stuff yeah yes
are you dating anyone i don't know
brandon
yeah me and kelsey are dating no no no
i mean that's like the one combination
that you guys haven't tried so
that's what we're talking about we're
like maybe like years from now that's
gonna
um alex has a new girlfriend did you
know her who is she
um she she and alex knew each other for
like
years i guess growing up and i was sort
of friends with her like
i have pictures with her from like
months ago and
um i know i knew her like she was always
offering to do my hair and
like i don't know and then they started
getting back together probably to make
me jealous but now they're just still
together and
like lord knows is she a cast member on
the season yes
okay but like not a lot i don't i think
it's like towards the end
or you're not going to see her in the
first episode or anything did you guys
ever watch laguna beach or the hills
growing up
mm-hmm my sister did watch this yeah a
lot
i watched like the last season of the
hills when heidi was getting surgery
and do you guys have such a great time
in pop culture yeah um
do you guys read spencercraft's recaps
of the show yeah yeah
all the way where you think about it
they're my favorite like i really like
art
yeah super shady yeah i'm like so
excited to see his recap of this first
episode like on to things too like he
catches things i feel like a lot of
viewers
right right that's so funny i love
watching his recap or reading them
okay so you guys live your life on tv
you do things
most time you regret because you guys
drink a lot on tv do you guys
ever and i find this happens a lot with
tv shows that i like to watch like we
loved about vanderpump rules
but you could definitely tell when
people get burnt out from like the
drinking and the fighting and
you guys are pretty young do you feel
yourself starting to get like
over the drinking like because it's so
much a part of
and i thought you guys on instagram when
you're off camera you guys don't stop
drinking oh no we never stopped
that's why i have like this is what
she's sick right now right i literally
like dropped throughout drinking
it's really bad no i don't get strep
throat i don't have my tonsils
um i mean you go more than we know we
like literally drink around the clock
and it's so crazy no we don't get right
now
are you guys gonna drink today um
i didn't drink too much he gets his ivs
because he's so thirsty
hydrated
i okay i don't know we just like
constantly like drink but i do know when
and when to like
stop not yeah like this is going to be
an important day i have to see
like this person don't get dressed
certain situations when you're around
people filming that you
want to get drunk
[Music]
you could see the sun setting so it's
like damn i was at
that bar for 12 hours right that's so
crazy where her graduation party was oh
my god
you can tell that i drank that yeah
there's a couple parties where i
definitely went over the edge
but it's hard to time it out because
you're there for so long that's the
thing you know because you start you
like you get there you feel a little bit
awkward sorry not awkward but you get
there you're just like sort of chilling
and you're like all right i'll have a
drink and then it leads into like four
yeah and then they're like all right
i'll be on in two hours
so now we're three seasons in people
know you guys really well they follow
you on social media
what do you think or what do you get
frustrated about like being the
biggest misconception about you guys
like individually like that people like
you see in your comments i'm like
i probably shouldn't say this but people
think i'm like the angel like i get that
comment on my instagrams that i'm like
an angel i'm like oh you are no
i think madison gets that a lot yeah
madison is definitely is she though is i
think she is
i don't know she's like really nice she
hasn't see us layers to it she has
she's layers yeah she's nice i just met
her she's so sweet
i think she's like definitely that like
brandon and madison are definitely the
nicest people
kelsey's nice
what would you say that is the biggest
misconception about you that doesn't
come off
in the show for me i'd say
i'm a girl but like i feel like i like
the [ __ ] voice sometimes on the show
you were saying the other day like your
sense of humor doesn't really get yeah
like my sense of humor is never shown on
the show or like i think i'm a lot
closer with a lot of the cast members
than
it appears yeah yeah but i don't know
are you still modeling
i'm trying but it's also when i'm in
siesta key yeah yeah
like actually a full-time job right yeah
like crazy
did you watch the show before you met
julia uh no
he didn't yeah you watch it actually
better now i've seen the first couple
episodes but
i was like please
[Music]
react live on camera because i know i'm
like who runs
garrett instagram they're savage
guys he's one of my favorite grades
so funny the christmas in new york city
is like no other
well actually he was like what do you
think about this one we were like oh
that's it
he's amazing he's really great you guys
you're probably watching right now like
oh my god
um and the theme song i just can't
stress enough how grateful i am that you
guys haven't changed it yet it's such a
great song
for everybody we're seeing jefferson
tonight oh my god
she's singing to the feeling yes yes oh
my gosh
does she know that like her song is on
her show she has to she has to know
she's
actually gonna ask her yeah i don't know
i think that's her greatest
accomplishment
she's cutting checks off everything
i mean i'm good it's like gonna be
iconic yeah i feel like it really it's
like unwritten by natasha
i feel like it really captures the
essence of cst you want to cut to the
feeling like the house is still using
unwritten
right different versions so i hope it
never changes every time it comes on
you're just like all right yeah
i come back it gives me like anxiety i'm
like oh
um okay so the new season premieres
january 7th on mtv obviously check it
out
you guys don't miss it don't miss it
just because why are you laughing
so much
literally claudia was like watching it
10 minutes ahead of me and she called me
and she made she like facetimed me and
watched me
watch it oh my god i was should we like
literally just don't expect one
i'm like rumors about this upcoming
season like alex and his girlfriend and
like honestly i don't even care like
what you see on this episode is so crazy
like
it's it's what everyone's going to be
talking about yeah and everybody there's
stuff going on with everyone
except alex wasn't in the first episode
thank you
alex plummer so make sure to follow
these guys on social media in case
you're missing anything that's going on
in their lives the new season premieres
january 7. thank you guys so much for
being here thank you thank you we love
csv thank you guys for listening to the
morning test monday morning show we go
live monday at the friday 10 30 and be
some time on youtube we're also going to
podcast pretty much every podcast
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow with brian kelly
bye
you